you know what's ironic though so in 20s
uh
I have big dreams and like there's like
big things I want to accomplish but I
actually don't have the skill set to do
it now I have the skills that they do it
I'm too tired
[Music]
welcome back everybody to
an episode of the careful boys and today
we have silent Mike back in the building
Michael am I a careful boy yeah how many
times yeah dogs at least 20 more times
you just gotta rep it hella hard and I
rep it I gotta tab it
this is your moment to declare yourself
well I actually had a question for you
guys what is it oh go ahead do we like
uh and and the three of y'all can play
but Joe and Bart are the G's okay top
five JK guests am I in the conversation
no no no no no not like coolest like I
know you deal vonnie's a little funnier
than me but I don't think you're
considered a guest anymore though
because we in my mind there's tears yeah
we have guests yeah that is safe that is
like is that a cop-out no no no so let
me explain
I I feel like so we have the family
which is this right and then we have we
have like the extended family and I
think you're a part of that like like
David would be extended family Colleen
would be extended family Mike you guys
you've been around so much like you were
you guys were extended family for a
minute because you were come come on so
often so then I don't even see them as a
guest a guest in my mind is someone
that's okay like not even occasional
we're probably not going to see him
again like they might come one time
maybe twice I'll take that yeah yeah
you're not you're definitely not the
David So category I'll take that you're
definitely not just a guess I'm just a
guy to you guys you guys just one and
done you're like the oh [__] somebody
canceled let's hit up Mike that's what
it feels like but I'll take it I feel
like when you come on you bring the heat
I'll try we always got good
conversations to come on thanks
you know it's easy to talk to you what
would it what would they say okay this
is kind of boring what's your question
uh it was definitely a little deeper and
more profound but we wanted to he tried
to hijack it with some stupid mystical
[__] top five guests of JK news
what's your top three favorite fingers
without the opposable you can't hold a
gun oh just thought we were just talking
about this right before right before the
camera's rolling me and Joe was talking
about
um the difference what we feel and how
we might articulate the true difference
between what it means to be in your 20s
versus in your 30s is everybody in their
30s not ever you just turned 30. and I
feel like there is a difference how
about you which also means there might
be some profound learning that you might
have from
what are you we're late 30s what are you
Anthony 36 right now 37 this year so you
guys are like mid yeah early
late yeah yeah that's a good news yeah
I'm 35 this summer because I think even
within 30s there's different stages
because early 30s still feel like late
20s I I saw this one Tick Tock where
this chick was saying like
30s are the babies of the adults
and I feel that and 20s are the adults
of the babies and then she says
something about 50 or 60 or 70 or
whatever but I was like oh [__] that's
true because like I feel like once
you're 30
you finally like really enter into the
conversation with adult adults like 30
40 50 year olds like people that have
like been working at a place for 20
years they they're doing adult [__] they
got [__] mortgages and kids and
whatever but then you're like the babies
of it you know yeah like you're just
starting your family just started
literally so you're like the babies of
the grown-ups yeah of the real girl
that's true in the world how much do you
think depends on like your path though
because all of us I have like similar
ish paths in what we did although very
different categories Yeah well yeah but
you know what I mean like you're kind of
working for yourself in some senses
you're kind of an entrepreneurial type
world and I don't know everyone's story
but most of us started in our early 20s
on this same Journey like we haven't
left this journey you know what I mean
where normally people go to college into
alert sometimes 25 totally different
Journey then they have like 12 different
jobs till they're 30 and then they
became the baby adult because they found
a career versus a job where a lot of us
found like careers in our 20s I think
you guys but I think just life
experience wise like knowing how it's
like I feel like I just now can go if
someone has problems with like I don't
know taxes or I got 30 parking tickets
now I hit collections like I've seen
enough life where I'm like okay I kind
of get a hold of what's what I'm saying
is I think you're ahead of most yeah
because people don't get that until
they're 40s normally oh really I think
so because so many people have like just
done College in like college and even
regular jobs everyone's telling you what
to do your schedule and your lifestyle
oh I get what you're saying we're like
you had to mature early you had to learn
how to do your taxes like 23. where some
people didn't yeah you know what I mean
no that that's true because that's like
um So within my group of employees at
jumbee there's a clear difference
between someone in college where it's
their very first job and they never
worked before versus people that uh been
working since 14 15 years old and and
the the they're just
their intelligence might be like
different right but the difference that
I see clearly is the mental and physical
endurance so people that's been working
very very early on like they could pull
a 12-hour shift or whatever yeah get her
done they they don't complain they just
like things are just normal whereas for
people it's their first time they freak
out a lot like they panic when there's a
rush they don't know what to do they
can't think on their feet and it's fine
because you know it's your first job
you're learning but the contrast is so
crazy to the point where there might be
a 20 year old and it's her first job
versus someone who's like 17 and the 17
year old feels like a 30 year old
so I think like life experience probably
does a lot to like the progress
depending on how old you are but for me
the difference between my own experience
with 20 to 30s is 30s I feel more
confident and more like relaxed yeah in
my 20s I'm so um I was in my head a lot
trying to prove myself I need to like do
this because it was like I have to have
this stuff speak for me and then I had a
lot of Pride to like prove right because
you're trying to like identify your your
your who you are and then you're not
sure of yourself so you have to prove
that hey I these are my dreams and I can
accomplish them and then you become a
person who can accomplish things but
before that it's all Theory it's all
like fake confidence in your head like
oh I can pursue my things and and do
what I say I'm gonna do but you can't
and know that until you do it and in
your 30s I think also your energy is a
little bit different you save your
energy at least for me like
um I'm not like wasting it everywhere
meaning like
I would Redline everything in my 20s
like whether it's a conversation or like
working out or something it would be a
thousand percent every time because I
thought that's how you had to do it but
then now I'm more like I pick and choose
do I want to have this conversation do I
want to spend my energy debating about
this topic with this person like how
much do I want to win in this fight or
whatever and I think like at this point
it's it's a lot easier to like chill and
think and I would say that's the biggest
difference that is a big one uh we were
just talking about this on the kid this
podcast actually
um in a similar light especially as like
artists and stuff like that right like
you're just a dreamer you're a [__]
thinker in that way and we were talking
about the idea that like in your 20s you
know you feel like you can go [__]
change the world you really just have
that in your mind you're like I could
change the world I can do some stuff you
just feel like you're fresh out of
college and you're like I can do some
[__] and in the 30s
you only give a [__] about protecting
your world you know what I'm saying like
your family your situation your
significant other or children or
whatever just like whatever the [__]
the world is happening around you we
were even saying this in our text there
recently right when we're looking at all
the [__] scams all these [__]
conspiracies going on and all it really
makes you want to do is buckle down and
make sure that your [__] is protected
you know what I mean and I think that
that was that's been a huge thing even
for myself you know because I do
remember the Ambitions and the dreams of
being in my 20s and seeing especially
even as a dancer like where I could go
and what I can do and I think having
those dreams does get you there
but then nowadays in my 30s it's a
totally different feeling it's a totally
different desire it's a it is a lot of
chill and think and save my energy and
stuff like that but I think there's a
huge shift between really believing you
can change the world and then really
actually only prioritizing and caring
about your world because you also
realize how stupid people are I mean
that's a huge thing I think in 20s like
let's say you're like a fitness
professional right you're like oh I'm
gonna make everyone fit it wasn't feel
so good and then later on in your 30s
like man so you just want to be fat dude
there's nothing I can do get out of my
head yeah there's nothing I can like
people have their own algorithm and you
can literally go here's the best program
here's the best meal plan here's
whatever like like then this person's
like get the [__]
like give me the donuts
because they're like all right I'm gonna
just focus on myself because when you're
in your 20s too you think you know
what's best so you want to change the
world because you want to like help
everybody but some people don't want
your [__] help and I think that's
what I learned in my 30s is just like
everyone's got their own lane so why
work hard
thinking that this is what they need
like they don't need it that's just
self-righteousness and I think like
um kind of going off of what you said
right like you don't have a ton of
people that you truly love in your 20s
the type of friends that you make it's
like drinking buddies it's like
oh we [__] play volleyball together
they're not real friends but the people
that stick with you through your 20s and
they last throughout into your 30s and
your whole family your real family that
you love that's when you go oh wait I'm
trying to like love the world and help
them and neglecting people that actually
matter and I think that's a big thing in
your 30s where it's like oh [__] I have
this whole group that's been loving me
why am I over here trying to fix these
people's problems when they don't even
want it I think that's a yeah that's a
big part of what you kind of mentioned a
lot of my stuff is a lot like Joe's like
uh Pace patience and like confidence in
the 20s were kind of like proof of
concept where yeah you have a little bit
of that fake confidence but you can't
have real confidence until uh it has
result right goal hit result and then I
have confidence that I can do things and
so now in my 30s although in my 20s I
would second-guess myself and I kind of
faked it to make it now I know because
of that concept worked I have more
confidence to have initiative and do
whatever the [__] I want you know what's
ironic though so in 20s uh
I have Big Dreams and like there's like
big things I want to accomplish but I
actually don't have the skill set to do
it now I have the skill set to do it I'm
too tired
from the ground up it could be very
successful but I'm not gonna do it I
think
I think I'm a little different than that
because like I don't really have a
family I have my mom but I don't have a
significant other I don't have kids I
know most of you guys have like a
significant other partner so some of my
energy is still very selfish in a sense
yeah
um so I still feel like I can kind of
Take On The World and I still have like
bigger plans which is cool obviously it
doesn't help my dating life because I'm
[__] still kind of selfish but uh
like I'm just so locked in we're like oh
you guys have to be like 70 locked in
and 30 to your like personal life so
that's a little bit different I feel
like I think it changes like family
building when your mind when you're not
a single guy and you're thinking about
family building like I don't have kids
or anything like that but if I'm
thinking seriously into like my 30s and
stuff then your whole set of dreams and
priority change like in my 20s I'm
thinking oh man I can't wait till I'm in
[__] Thailand getting my dick sucked
by five girls and then on top of that
we're gonna [__] we're gonna Skydive
and like your dreams are like almost see
the world and eat every single different
[__] kinds of [__] fur or whatever
right that sounds good
but now I think the 30s dreams I can see
myself going man we're gonna have some
cool ass kids running around chasing
puppies and [__] we're going to be
growing tomatoes in our backyard and
then your thoughts and what you desire I
think completely shift depending on who
your partner is too so some of that uh I
can't relate to at all because I feel
like my family stuff switched right away
so dad died when I was 23 and my mom was
in this country by herself she has no
family no nothing and dad was mom had a
job and she's fine but Dad was the
provider so at 23 I'm like make money
say Mom what do we do how do I get my
mom's Tomatoes yeah you guys you guys
been a team since you're 23 for the last
11 years and and nothing else right
nothing else matters so how do I work
how do I provide for mom how do I
provide for me and how does this last
the next 50 years for myself and my mom
so like I never I never want to get my
dick sucked by a [__] and wherever
you were headed
yeah
you know what I mean so that's where I
meant we're like depending on where your
path goes I think your brains or goals
switched in different areas right or
like what about the kids sense of
urgency changes yeah what about the kid
that never had a family in there in
foster care but still are driven they
probably are a different human at 17
than we were all yeah true yeah you know
they probably never had an orphan yeah
family yeah maybe or they never had
their drinking years or whatever because
they couldn't afford to so maybe they
have no friends or whatever and so I
feel like that person at 24 is probably
me at 34. you know or vice versa and the
opposite you know I have dated people in
their 30s that are [__] living a
college life you know what I mean they
have a set job a set life and then they
just get I mean you guys know them too
just get hammered every weekend because
they have no other ideas of life or what
to do no like real goals or initiative I
do feel like though humans constantly
chase a void like whatever you didn't
have or what you want to recreate you
constantly go through that so it's like
we don't all live the same lives but
generally we can't speak generally like
if you're going through the system from
like and you and you have a generally
normal
quote-unquote like family or whatever
everyone progresses at the same rate
sure so then it's you can kind of gauge
like at this at this decade you're
probably going to experience this yeah
and each decade you're probably going to
experience I wonder how different it was
though right like because everyone's
having kids so different now and it's
only one generation my dad got graduated
college for whatever at 23 and
automatically got a six-figure job out
of college right because that's what
happened back then yeah right so he
moved he bought a condo in San Jose
married my mom at like 24 started having
kids imagine all us having kids at 24
like that's [__] I would ruin that
kid's life I would ruin my own life like
you know what I mean like even being
married that early seems so crazy to us
but I assume a lot of your guys's
parents also got married early and
that's that's one generation difference
I think we prolong childhood now because
like if you think about stories from our
grandparents they were working as
children yeah there weren't no [__]
laws like that or some of them would be
doing Apprentice work yeah and then if
you hear stories about like you know
people coming into America as a child in
the 19 like tens or whatever like
they've been working and then they
become like a mogul or whatever unless
college so like everyone's working at
18. yeah
yeah getting into college is a crazy
concept yeah it's weird not everyone and
now a lot of people go to college and
they don't work until their early 20s or
even if that 30s bro I know people 30s
their first job like the first career
type job like maybe they'll do a Jamba
Juice or something oh yeah yeah but like
not like a job that is a good point
though like it does seem that we're
almost on this like exponential
Evolution I don't want to say like
maturity but just like Evolution as a
peoples as a human species in such a way
where like generation like one
generation ago [__] was so different
yeah that is kind of evidence to
basically say that one generation from
now shit's gonna be way different yeah
probably doubled you know what I'm
saying so it's kind of like the taika
this is what this is also one of my
friends and if we put in perspective
like how long have humans been on this
Earth
millionaires maybe that's cool it
depends on what you okay yeah what do
you believe in
it's like uh
what do you believe I think it's like 70
000 or something well it depends depends
oh wait wait uh that's farming so that's
civilization I think okay so let's say
70 000 in a civilization right sure
we technically only this generation and
the last generation were the only
generation out of the 70 000 years where
we started to think about what our
passions were
um yeah so that's how drastic that
[__] J curve is before it's just
survival yeah how do I not get eaten how
do I plant some [__] wheat whatever
and I starve now it's like
a [__] video or whatever right like
it's literally that that's true I miss
ice skating I want to ice skating
just this and the last generation we're
the only ones be happy yeah yeah it's
not crazy I mean for the most part
people were just Farmers yeah yeah and
then it wasn't until the Industrial
Revolution where people had jobs 100
years ago that was like yeah literally a
hundred years ago or so the passion work
thing was like within the less last 20.
yeah so before that people just worked
because they needed they needed to serve
what paid good yeah I think there could
have been societies that that did have
that but they all fell right yeah
from an analytics standpoint what is the
majority age demographic of our
followers
uh 18 to 35. so in this generation so I
know that maybe you don't relate to the
70 000 year old farmer gatherer stuff
like that but in this generation Mozart
mid-20s to late 20s yeah that's our
that's our family you know it's a pretty
very simple thing at least the way I see
it for Creative is um early 20s
I have an idea of what I want to be I
want to do this thing and I'm good at it
late 20s I did the thing early 30s hey
all these other people had the same idea
that I did I did that before late 30s
I was that same person in my early 20s
early 40s why am I broke and followed
the artist's life yeah why aren't I on
Tick Tock but creatively creatively it's
that cycle of like you think you had
this thing but everybody thinks I had a
thing and then 10 years later someone
else never knew you had it or did it and
it starts over it's like you can't get
mad at it this is extremely pragmatic
and maybe boring in terms of regular
conversation but I will say there's one
thing that I wish I did in my 20s that I
started in my early 30s and it was
literally basic saving investing because
it's one of those things from a
mathematics point of view if you're
talking about like the year-over-year
compound interest yeah the person who
starts at 20 is going to be way richer
than the person who starts at 30 even
though it seems like such a short Gap
but at 20 you're so [__] busy
dreaming nobody could have told you that
like you would have just not either not
done it or you would have pulled your
money out at some point exactly you know
what I'm saying but like if at the
[__] the just the young 20 year old
would just do you know what I mean what
the 30 year old is doing now you we'd be
so much better better off one benefit of
that though is like it's cool all of a
sudden it's cool to invest all of a
sudden it's cool it's cool to be a
business owner it's cool to work hard 18
to 35 year olds out there 35 is not too
late but if you're a [__] in your 18s
or early 20s yo start now when it's when
it doesn't feel like you have the money
whatever start in our in our 20s we
didn't have access to stocks like that
yeah like right now you can you needed a
you need to go through Brokers you need
to do that dude like yeah it was a
different game the only thing we had was
Certificate of Deposits at the [__]
bank and you had to go to the bank yeah
yeah you had to go there people used to
go to the bank yeah you haven't been to
a bank in so long yeah you can't just
take a picture of a check and deposit I
haven't been no pain you [__] gotta
[__] take that [__] in there
damn pragmatic but serious that's the
crazy thing too is that imagine starting
a savings in your 20s how many things
that have happened in the past few years
would you have taken that out and
reinvested into that anytime new rims
came up exactly like
you would have taken all that [__] out
and went oh no way my inflation's gonna
kill that I'm gonna put it here and then
well then at least you would have
learned that same lesson that some of us
30 year olds learned yeah
true oh yeah oh yeah me and Joe about to
be 40 next year that's crazy crazy y'all
still look 20 for real that's because
I'm 25.
wait we're 39 now we're gonna be 39 this
year oh yeah this year it's 30. next
will be 40. we're about to have 40s and
30s conversations
and that hat kind of make you look 50
though and then it's just the answer is
gonna be I don't remember anymore
we're still doing this
thank you